[Music]  the keyboard player from Star Fox in the  flesh tomorrow I am NOT gonna spend  another 10 years waiting for a shot this  this right here is my shot if tomorrow  goes well we're gonna blow up and that  means we're gonna be used to clean  sold-out crowds after all night sex and  drug binges so we might as well start to  get used to do you know what the murder  rate is in Palm Springs Jackie wait you  think this was a murder never hear the  prisoner's dilemma  whoever rats the other one out first  walks free  [Music]  plan that showing where what it's a  man's life have no return  you used us I used you you're  unbelievable  every man for himself we're really doing  this we're really doing this we have a  problem  she's our fearless leader you're out of  the band dude you've heard the story we  were supposed to tell you I'll tell you  the truth  [Music]  you  you